if you can't see the clock uh try
opening your eyes
i'm hiding the chat again
okay wow this is a fast-paced tournament
i'm trying to recover as best as i can
thank you seyrack
with a sub so i'm playing this um
this is a fun line go for h6 rookie 8.
so mainline's 92 a5 and 93 is also
possible
staccato or vibrato which one is it
thanks for subbing
so there's a trap here castling bishop
h2 because greek gift
um so h3 is probably natural
a3 is natural yeah this is all still
prep
this is a casa corley variation
oh another sub sultan central term baby
two term wait does that mean 18 months
oh eight months oh congratulations
oh rook d1 i remember this move
i think casa corley ran into this at
some point
but he still went for no he went for
bishop d7 i think
i'm not sure if i'm remembering
correctly but the idea is you allow
white to play this because knight g5
would prevent f3 but i want white to
play f3
i i want white to go for this plan
and then when white plays this and i i
do crazy things takes
takes takes takes takes and then blocks
winning yeah let's go
this is the right move order i think
a white premium of that thinking i was
going to take with pawn
i'm pretty sure casa corley had this
exact same position
against the strong gm um
but with the rook on d1 i usually have
the position with the bishop here and
the rook still here
i had that against kashlin skya
this i am not a gm a speed chess
championship
so one of the ideas is if e5 i just take
it with a rook
you basically sacrifice a rook for this
diagonal
yeah this is so nice
i've had this a few times in like uh
online games
this is still prep basically
so knight e4 only move
oh it's actually trickier because the
bishop's defended there's another line
wait a minute
oh this is still winning though so
knight d4 takes king here it takes here
um i don't need to take the bishop i
just take the pawn
i think
rook f2 rook f2 is new new for me
i have this move
bishop h2 is a threat or bishop h7 is a
threat
um i just don't want to mess this up so
i'm going to take time here
this move oh this should be winning yeah
queen g3
because the rook's pinned king f1 i take
on h3
the king e2 i then destroy the bonhoed
with mate so
um king e1's only move
i mean i'm winning a lot of pawns also
this is coming
i am down to full rook so always got to
be careful
the smooth
and this should be a simple calculation
let's just take a little bit of time so
if i play this
king here here i win the rook so bishop
f1 only move
and then i just take
but then rook takes
i can take on e5 or i can just take
hmm
there's this move this move which isn't
quite winning
now this might be trickier than
i would like
[Music]
rookie
i don't want to do this but i feel like
i have to i have a lot of pawns for this
i have a lot of i have five pawn i have
five pawns for a night
okay um but it's still
like from a practical standpoint it's
not so simple
it's still going to take a lot of work
to win this especially with time
look here i probably just trade
also some queen g5 idea
um h5
idea bishop g4 so just block the file
this is called a four post when there's
a pawn defending a minor piece to block
a file
i gotta keep up the pace
this is okay if ticks i play queen g5 i
take back
and the pawn pawn is marching
should join the marching band
that still takes work though
might as well rook lift
let me get i have to be careful
i have to be very careful here
that's not the move i wanted to play
let's go okay i want i took work wow
i remember casa had like a similar game
it may have been the same line where
like he
yeah he let the advantage slip and ended
up drawing
um but that was fun opening preparation
i don't get that line too often but
that's like one of the deepest lines
that strong players will still sometimes
fall into
victory bits i miss mates i don't know
if i missed me
but maybe i did
oh of course it was really good
oh oh i just have to play a quiet move i
need a bishop move
well i was running this
that's kind of hard to understand though
that you just kind of wait
if i can't do anything
um it seems like i didn't quite miss me
unless it was here
oh i missed this move tactics
anyway yeah i had some cool games i've
never been to egypt